welcome for the first time the author of
this book that I have right here in
front of me grateful American a journey
from self to self service that is gonna
be ready we're all books are sold widely
next Tuesday February 12th the Academy
Award nominated Emmy award-winning actor
Gary Sinise how are you sir I'm great
thanks Fran what a pleasure to have you
right here
thank you you bet why write this book
where did this book come from Gary well
I'm you know I've been in around done a
few things and I was encouraged to to
think about it as time went on I've been
doing a lot of work for military and our
veterans community our first responders
I've been overseas I've been all around
and done a lot of that created a
foundation and all of that so I thought
we'd track a little of the journey from
self to service it's not journey from
selfish to service it's just from a
focused singular focus on what I was
doing in my career and that kind of
think to a broader focus of service to
others and and it's a pretty pretty
interesting journey I think you know
kind of bumbled along for a while and
then all of a sudden things started to
happen so I know many folks might just
by hearing your voice knew recognized
your voice from the US Army commercials
for sure as well as obviously from from
your acting career Forrest Gump playing
the famed Lieutenant Dan character is
that where your connection with Armed
Forces and having you as an individual
and actor connected to it is that where
that comes from well that's part of it
but you know I have a lot of military in
my family so I'm on both my side of the
family and my wife side of the family so
it kind of starts there and then years
ago I got very involved with Vietnam
veterans groups in Chicago I have a
theater company that I talk about in the
book that I started with my pals called
Steppenwolf Theatre in Chicago and when
I was working there back in the late 70s
early early 80s I got very involved with
some local Vietnam veterans groups
started supporting them in different
ways
helped create Veterans Memorial in
Lansing Illinois we started some
programming at Steppenwolf focused on
supporting veterans and that was a full
10 12 years before I actually played
Lieutenant Dan in Forrest Gump so by the
time I had the the audition opportunity
sure when that came along I was kind of
tuned into supporting veterans already
and very much wanted to play that part
and was lucky to get it no kidding yeah
because of Europe because if you were
connection already to the military
that's yet led you wanting to take the
role of lieutenant death to Vietnam
veterans sure particularly aiiow Vietnam
veterans my my family on my wife's side
of the family or two brothers her
sister's husband I've been working with
Vietnam veterans supporting them in
different ways you know they kind of got
crapped on when they when they came home
from war it was a terrible time in our
history very divided nation and the and
the the service members kind of fell
through the cracks and bad things
happened and and so I just started
trying to give back to them in different
ways and so when this opportunity came
along in the mid 90s to audition for
this guy and he's a wounded veteran
that's right
you know I very much wanted to play it I
was lucky to get the part and never
imagined that it would play a greater
role in my life than just a movie part
but it but it actually did yeah I want
to dig it a little bit a little bit more
Gary Sinise here on the Rich Eisen show
you played a character in Lieutenant Dan
not just wounded physically but mentally
and we're seeing that so much with
military members that are coming home
from theaters from serving overseas we
have a ton of veterans who listen and
take in this show and that was so moving
in that film Gary that that you know the
magic legs is what obviously Forrest
Gump called your legs but you the Hallie
you were upset that he actually saved
you because your character was supposed
to die in the field of battle like
everybody before him I'm wondering if
that's what spoke to you when you got
the script there's no part of it I mean
it was a it was a you know the way the
structure of the the character in the
he's only in the movie about 20 minutes
I mean if you look at it there's little
sections of him 2025 minutes worth but
it was a great story because in the end
a guy who's going through a lot of
post-traumatic stress he's dealing with
his own guilt from walking his platoon
into an ambush getting a lot of them
wounded or killed he's blown up himself
he just didn't want to survive that
that's a he's got a lot of survivor's
guilt there because of it and that's so
that's a typical understandable thing
for many warriors coming home from war
but the good thing about that story and
we hadn't seen that prior the Forrest
Gump really in a movie about Vietnam or
a Vietnam veteran was that he's okay in
the end he's standing up again he's on
legs he's clean-cut he's rich he's made
a lot of money in the shrimping business
you know he's you know they they did
well he invested in Apple and he made a
lot of money and that was a story about
a Vietnam veteran that we just hadn't
seen somebody who could come back from
war go through the understandable
anguish and and despair and all the
things that he was dealing with but in
the end come around and do okay that's
the story that we want for every single
veteran coming home from war is that
they were able to push through their
experience into war and and move on with
it and that's what I'm that's what I'm
just trying to trying to help folks do
one that one of the producers of Forrest
Gump owns the New York Giants and Steve
Tisch and and he's the only guy to have
an Oscar and a Lombardi Trophy yeah on
planet Earth which is something he's
very very pleased that's pretty cool
yeah he doesn't have an Emmy though he's
working on an ego as well I don't know
how you work the or they be like the SB
got you know with a Super Bowl trophy in
there or something like that so do you
have any specific repairs fan you
mentioned you're from Chicago sure okay
like what is your how deep is your love
for Chicago sports and you know my team
in Chicago's the cups I grew up watching
the Cubs you know I'm a bear fan and
everything but I'm really a big baseball
fan so love the Chicago Cubs
since I was five years old talk about it
in my book a little bit who is a guy was
it what was your gone Sano was was my
game well I was you know I was a big fan
we went went in into the playoffs in
1969 so I remember that team very
specifically and it was and I wanted to
be a third baseman and Ron Santo was my
guy and I get to meet him later on and
spend some time up in the booth with him
and that kind of thing as as time went
on a great great team there have great
memories of that and I have great
memories of sitting in front of a
black-and-white television
five years old watching the Cubs on WGN
in Chicago and I lived on the south side
where the White Sox are so but I'm a Cub
fan and it's simply because I watched
him on television on WGN from the time I
was five five years old so yeah I assume
you've crossed paths with Harry Caray at
some point oh sure yeah yeah I'm way
back when you know you know way back
when that was sure I know you could I I
met Harry once when I was I went to
Northwestern in graduate school oh you
did I did okay I did I went to and and I
covered the as a student I covered the
announcement I think of Jim Riggleman
was the the newly named manager and it
was at 10:00 in the morning was the
press conference and I went to Wrigley
Field at 10:00 in the morning and who
was there just me and him in the room
but Harry Caray
oh no Ken and he was several sheets to
the wind
if I I think it was a Bloody Mary and
that Mary she it was bloody oh yeah holy
cow
holy cow have you done the take me out
to the ballgame oh sure many times how'd
that go for you it's pretty great it's
pretty great to do it I just try to do
it like Harry you know when I'm there
yeah so you get into it oh yeah yeah
there's plenty of videos out there it's
a lot it's a lot of fun I enjoy it a lot
doing it I was gonna do it last year but
some things came and came up and I
couldn't get there but usually I'm there
you know I'll go there at least once a
year and what did it mean to you to see
them finally win it what did it mean to
you to see them fun oh my gosh are you
kidding
if I mean for all of us who grew up Cub
fans you know that that was just the
greatest night of all time
we're just where'd you take it were you
there at home no no I couldn't be there
i stiii watched it at home amazing yeah
Gary Sinise here on the Rich Eisen show
and working with Hanks Tom Hanks you got
a good Tom Hanks story forming here
because you've worked in three of them
with him right yeah yeah Apolo Ohno
tom-toms sounds a great guy just we did
three movies together in the 90s Forrest
Gump Apollo 13 and the Green Mile Green
Mile just a little part but I got to
work on that for a couple of days and
Apollo 13 was was tremendous we got to
do all kinds of cool things you know we
went up in the kc-135 training plane
which is it's a tanker a case is c-135
tanker they call it the vomit comet
named that they've got it all carved out
inside there's only a few seats in the
back everything's padded and they drop
you into zero-gravity for about 25
minutes 25 seconds and we got to float
around in there together so who handled
it the best I well why don't we just say
who handled it the worst you and it was
me yeah there's a funny picture in the
book where you see when you go and when
you go up you get flight suits and they
you have pockets here one pocket here in
one pocket here and they they'll give
you two little plastic bags mm-hmm just
in case you need them and there's only
one guy who comes back with one plastic
bag and I was amazing yeah I'm looking
some of these photographs there there
you are as Truman which you see all of
us there we all have two plastic bags in
our pocket there yeah the top right
right and then right underneath I'm
coming down the stairs after the plane
after the plane lands and I've got one
missing fantastic
there you are as Truman as well you want
your Emmy Award for that and obviously
so many other great roles
you want a Golden Globe for for Truman
so you yeah you won you're a me for
George Wallace as a matter of fact my
bad on all that and I see a photograph
you sit next to W I see you sitting next
to the president in the United States
that well that was that was for a
nonprofit that I started called with
Laura Hillenbrand who wrote Seabiscuit
and the book unbroken and we started a
program called Operation Iraqi children
which was a school supply program we
started shipping school supplies over
the troops during the Iraq war and they
would take them out and give them to the
kids I write about it in the book and a
bunch of nonprofits that were supporting
the military and veterans got invited to
the White House that day for a meeting
to talk about how we could promote that
we were supporting our veterans and so
there were lots of nonprofits there that
I'm just one of them well I'm pleased to
have you here again the book and you
said you're just about to start on a
book tour for this and we're your first
up yeah the book comes out February 12th
and I go on a start on a tour on the
10th grateful American a journey from
self to service and on the back you got
some testimonials from Tom Hanks Joe
Montaigne I think you probably met him
in Chicago yeah oh yeah we're old
friends oh yeah he goes way back there
in Clint Eastwood on the back as well
Tom dreesen I mean that is another I
mean you got a lot of Chicago
connections right here congratulations
on this book and I'm a big fan of your
work thanks for coming in here thanks so
much
you bet Gary Sinise at Gary Sinise on
Twitter Gary Sinise official on
Instagram grateful American a journey
from self to service by Gary Sinise
available we're all books are sold
on February 12th the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience